as a sniper like being able to see
something and
the intent behind it was more personal
every sniper kill that i had felt
different
some people say oh you get used to it i
never felt that are you at a point right
now where you can live your normal life
and it doesn't haunt you anymore
i would say i am now who's the greatest
sniper of all time carlos hathcock
a marine sniper that was my idol and i
think that
to this day that he is the best sniper
godlike figure
to me when he went in to go take out the
vietcong commander surrounded by himself
was
basically a suicide mission when he
attached the universal stove to the
mod dude's 50 cal machine gun and sniped
and took out a vietnamese commander he's
like 1.2 miles away
and that was where we get the barrett
sniper rifle from to this day the
semi-automatic first confirmed versus
the last confirmed was there a meaning
behind the last one
not my last kill my last mission i lost
my friend benjamin cobb
i almost lost my life my reconnaissance
team pinned down
by an enemy sniper and surrounded and
watching the guy come in to save
our life and watching him die like five
minutes after that
that was my determining factor i was not
going to re-enlist or anything
[Music]
my guest today is nicholas irving aka
the reaper
who is a sniper and not only any sniper
he was the first
black sniper in army's third ranger
battalion that was deployed
in combat i believe he has 33 confirmed
kills in a matter of four months and a
tour to afghanistan
and he he had a nickname for his well i
just let him tell you when we get right
into it so
nicholas having said that thank you so
much for being a guest on
hey thank you for having me on so first
of all thank you for your service you
know for somebody to get in and
and then you know you go from fort
benning you go to afghanistan you got
your 33 kills and you're putting
yourself on the line and
there's a lot of risk on that but uh
what
what made a person like you say i want
to be a sniper how does that happen
to be honest it was well i would say
charlie sheen but that stems from
the movie navy seals but it derives from
my dad
both of my parents were um in the army
uh that's where my parents met that's
where i was born i was born in augsburg
germany
um while they were both uh in the
military and seeing my dad
at a young age i had to be maybe four
years old
and i watched him raise the flag one day
um at his building and he was wearing
the army green uniform and i thought
that was the coolest thing ever
and it kind of intrigued me ever since
then i wanted to be like my dad so
wearing his military uniform and asking
questions and
watching movies about the military and
reading books it it started as a
very very very young kid and my mom and
my dad
wow what was your dad's own wes
they were both uh they both had the same
mos they were counterintelligent so
uh geez i don't know exactly maybe at 90
something i honestly have no idea what
the uh
mos was but they were counter
intelligence during the cold war
so they like did morse code and stuff
like that so so they're they i mean you
have to score very high on the asvab to
get
any kind of military intelligence so
your parents are very well i couldn't do
it
yeah i was not there i didn't fall about
it have that
yeah i remember when i went and took my
test and they came back with the score
they said yeah you got two options i
said what is it
infantry or hummer mechanic i said you
know what i will play with hummers a
little bit so i took homeroom
so that's a good choice so so sniper so
walk me through
what i what i don't know of is so
you you go in you know you got boot camp
you know i don't know if it's nine weeks
12 weeks they keep changing it so
whatever the timeline is then you have
ait
advanced individual training and you
have any kind of secondary you know
schools that you take what is the
process of becoming a sniper if you can
walk us through it
um for my i have a special operation so
the the pipeline or the cycle was a
little bit extended so i did the
you're right i think it was 14 weeks
with the army basic training
plus the ait uh they changed it to where
the
basic training and ait's all combined
now and they
they call it ocit when i went in it was
one station unit training
i believe it was 14 weeks and
right after that uh was airborne school
uh that five weeks of you know getting
used to
heights which i'm you know terrified of
and
learning how to jump out of planes and
uh you should have five jumps
uh out of right out of airborne school
after airborne school i went to a
selection course for rangers which was
called
ranger indoctrination program are ripped
for short
and that was about a that was a
month-long course of
just a physical beat down and we had 85
85 plus guys or candidates that uh tried
out for this selection and
we graduated seven uh six of the
original class and i was one of the six
from that original class and
everybody else quit or could not make
the standards and
from there i went on to my unit third
ranger battalion
and stayed there for six months did
my first deployment to iraq two
deployments after that we would deploy
every
six months so we would deploy for uh
three months four months and
come back and train up for six and keep
that rotation up and i did three
deployments to iraq before i went to
uh sniper school after that
then i officially well i had a few jobs
before that i was a
machine gunner a machine gun team leader
so i had my own little machine gun team
and
designated marksman the step or the
process or the
designator right before sniper you're
not officially a sniper you haven't gone
to the schooling yet
but you have a scoped weapon and you're
you score
expert a lot um held that for a little
for one deployment
before i officially went on to sniper
school which was eight weeks long
and uh before that i had
like our units special operations we had
courses we would get sent to so
uh private courses um i went through uh
two sniper schools that were not through
the military they're a private civilian
run from
guys who are really really good at
shooting and we're like outsourced to
whatnot that's why i learned how to
shoot
you know i think the best when it came
to precision shooting
nicholas was that was that out of the
country
oh here's stateside and coincidentally
it was here in texas where i ended up
moving to
um where i got my first case i guess for
texas i had never seen land that flat
before
and it wasn't i don't know it was
beautiful and that's why i like texas
initially
and uh yeah went through two sniper
schools in texas
one in california a little high angle
precision shooting course that was
privately run and then to
the eight week sniper course um so yeah
it's a long long long fight that's
pretty intense
so so you got your one uh station unit
training
airborne school you have to jump five
times and you go selection
then you go four months ranger school
out of 85 seven you were one of the six
third battalion then afghanistan and you
deployed three times to iraq then
in that process of sniper school i
forgot there yeah
there was a ranger you totally i blocked
this purposely out of my mind
terrible school it's brutal ranger
school so after
you know you serve in the range of
battalion then we go to the 70 or 62 day
ranger school and that's just uh you
know they starve you for
you know however 62 days i lost 35
pounds in that school
and i didn't sleep much so i got sick
and it was a bad bad experience you'd
normally lose a lot of weight
about 20 pounds but i lost 35 and had to
deploy after that so
i purposely forget about that school so
after that then was sniper school
then it was nicer so so sniper school
you know is is it you know how you're
going like what i didn't know is
you and i can join the navy and while
we're signing up to go into the navy we
can say we want to go to
be a navy seal i don't know you could do
that right off the bat right i thought
it's kind of like you go in
and then you say hey i want to be an 18
billion time go become i'm part of the
fifth group or third group of whatever
yeah
so is sniper something you requested
from day one or was it something that
came later on
it came later on um got it so yeah like
when i first had my contract i wanted to
ask that but there was no way they had
no idea
you know if i could shoot no way of
knowing if i could shoot well
or anything like that a team player if i
would even make it so
it was not even an option i wish it
would i wish it were
but at the time is there automatic
elimination that
okay listen we like you you're great
but here's five things that
automatically eliminates you from being
in sniper school you know how back in
the days they would say if you're
colorblind if you're flat-footed if you
have asthma you know all these things
that would say was there any automatic
disqualification of sniper school
oh yeah i had my first run in uh
being colorblind when i wanted my before
i wanted to join the army i wanted to be
a navy seal like everybody else does
and you know i went into i did the whole
process
i was talking to the navy recruiter i
went to a navy seat cadet corps my mom
put me through
or you know i asked her to be in and i
went through this
a little program called baby seals and
they put you through like a little uh
mock
navy seal course and you you know get
scuba qualified and all this
like 15 and i thought that was pretty
neat and i went into the navy recruiter
and
i took the color vision test and it
turned out that i was 100
not 100 but i was red green colorblind
and completely disqualified me so i went
to the army
thinking that i could fool them and
somehow
cheat this television test not
not with the intention of wanting to
join the army but retaking this
television test
and failed it again but this army nurse
was there and she kind of like i was
crying a lot you know it was a dream
that i had of one to join the military
and
i was crying in the office or the little
station where you uh take your physical
let
and she saw me crying and she brought me
into her office and asked what the
problem was and
found out that i was red green
colorblind so she pulled out this
booklet
and she traced with her finger all the
numbers that i couldn't see
and i called them out and she scored me
that's how i got into the army
i had no idea what a ranger was until i
i remember watching black hawk down but
it didn't stand out to me i didn't find
out what rangers were
and you know pretty much until i you
know signed the contract
and was going in so so neither ranger or
neither sniper was negotiated up front
no oh just ranger ranger was negotiated
i asked for
i wanted something that was going to be
the closest to navy seals as possible
they said rangers was in except for
rangers they don't swim
and i was like well perfect i'll take
that and that's how i became a ranger
got it yeah i mean ranger is uh it's
you know i i i know rangers and they
tell me the story and it's not
a not easy no no no not i mean seven on
eighty five eighty five goals seventy
seven come out that's uh
those are the numbers for you so sniper
school were there any automatic
disqualifications or no
yes um i don't have 20 20 vision and
so if you have television and 20 20
vision
um if they cannot be corrected that
automatically disqualifies you um
i don't think there was anything else as
far as being flat-footed
got it uh but basically eyesight was the
the number one thing that would
immediately disqualify you did they
recruit you to become a sniper or did
you make the ask
i had to i had to ask my my platoon my
first my team leader
then it went up the chain of command
before i could actually become
or put in the paperwork you have to put
in this packet um
that's signed off by your chain of
command you're worthy of going they
trust that you'll
go and represent well and you're a team
player or
you know all these you know uh little
pre-qualifications in this packet that
you have to
have submitted to sniper school they
look at it they only accept so many
uh per year and that's when the courses
start
five weeks eight weeks long and uh
yeah day one it's you know the first day
i want to take that back the first day
you can get cut pretty easily
where they shoot in it's called a shoot
in process where they give you a
standard ar m4 rifle iron sights
no scope on it and you have to be able
to shoot a
a grouping like five inch grouping and i
forget how
far 25 meters or something like that um
and if you can't that immediately
disqualifies you day one
it's you know your bags are not even
unpacked and that can get you
disqualified
right off the bat day one oh yeah that
happened we had like two guys in our
class we went in
and literally bags still packed
as soon as we got there an hour or two
as soon as uh class initially started
they were already back home yeah so it's
pretty quick it's not like so they're
immediately getting
it's not like they're getting rid of 50
but they're getting rid of the bottom
five percent bottom ten percent oh yeah
there you go yeah exactly so so then
what was it like i mean if you go is it
i'm assuming i'm assuming sniper school
has to be very different than ranger or
iran like there's no screaming because
it's more poised you have to stay calm
i'm assuming it's a different angle they
took different directions they take with
sniper school
100 it was a i want to say laid
a little bit more laid back there was
rarely anybody that yelled
no none of the instructors or anything
it was like a personal
uh it was not like what you expect
when you turn on and look at like drill
sergeants are getting yelled at and
stuff like that it was a really
uh gentleman's course if you want to
call it that uh uh
you're your own you have your own
responsibilities and you know you're a
sniper you have to get used to working
as
one man or two man very small small
teams and have a lot of responsibilities
so
we had a lot of you know leeway when it
came to that not a lot of yelling or
fussing
the i guess the the hard portion of
sniper school that you know really
stands out
is the attention to detail there there's
a lot of attention to detail that is
you know uh incorporated with sniper
school it's not all shooting i would i
would honestly say the
shooting portion maybe makes up 20 30
of all cyber school everything else is
learning there's eight hour 12 hour days
of sitting
in a classroom staying awake watching
hours of powerpoint
or going out to the field and learning
you know how to read the wind
are looking for you know a toothpick or
toothbrush in the woods with the
binoculars and stuff like that a lot of
attention to detail
not much shooting that was the hard part
not what i expected
so finding a toothpick or a toothbrush
in the woods like
you you have to find it so you're
literally sitting there and you have to
find the toothbrush
yep so there's a portion called target
detection and
they place out small objects uh in the
in the field
you know 100 yards a couple hundred
yards or however far away in front of
you
and you use your naked eyes binoculars
and your spotting scope to find
these ten small objects it might be a
bullet um
a string a military shoelace
toothbrush small small stuff like that a
clear protractor was one i distinctly
remember
a clear protractor taped to the side of
a building
and what made it stand out were the
numbers like the little tick marks that
are not normally on the side of a
building so
attention to detail looking for really
small things that don't fit
that was really really you know
harpdonus cyberschool
nicholas when you go to when when i meet
a ranger
or a special forces or delta these are
all gung-ho guys like you look at them
you're like
i'm respect you know you see a studs
you start up studies right when you see
i know that look oh yeah yeah
yeah so you you you know but you can see
like
this makes sense right you get this when
when you went to sniper school
did you see a commonality amongst the
soldiers like
was it extremely technical was it
quieter was it more
shy reserved was it a lot of loners was
it a lot of
you know i'm not a you know i'm more
like like sports you know some kids do
better at tennis because it's a one-man
game or golf or boxing
versus team 20 30 40 50 people what what
expense did you notice about this
microphone
you know i never really thought about it
that but now looking back at it that's a
really good question
and i would say it's a really wow the
commonality would be
i would say the loner aspect everyone
has that
i guess they were the nerds or maybe
didn't have that many friends in school
not because of it was just they chose to
maybe
um quieter more reserved
people who like to think a lot are
people who think more than they talk
you know i would say that was one of the
biggest characteristics of
you could tell a sniper if you put them
in the crowd of people you would be able
to tell
who the sniper is they don't look like
the chiseled
you know you know guy you see on the
poster or anything like that they were
just
like your average really really
average average average guy nothing
stand out
nothing standoutish very average guy
some guys i looked at and i was just
like i don't know what you're doing here
you know
but there was one guy on my team and i'm
not like uh we all made fun of him but
he was very um he wasn't he caught he
knew he was not attractive to the eye
you know and he was just a very average
very below maybe a little bit below
average looking guy maybe
and but he was the best shot and he
outshot
everybody on the team the best shot to
this day if i had to go up against this
guy i would lose
the best pure talent best shot
i've ever seen in my life but as far as
looks you would not be able to tell
he was really really heavy in the like
wwf
or wwe he was into wrestling as a grown
man so it was uh
that's how average it was very
interesting so
you know did you did you guys i'm
assuming there's a level of camaraderie
built is there follow-up till today
where you guys keep contact with each
other is there some kind of a
you know community of snipers being
friends together
big time big time it's a huge unity i i
talked to my spotter
to this day to uh uh not spotter my
original spotter i talked to and i have
a friend that was not my spotter but we
were in the same sniper
platoon together we still we i mean hung
out
for years after we got out the military
we shot at this little facility
help instruct different military units
at a facility that we
went to go shoot at one point in our
careers and
keep in contact we've been in business
together
um and this my old team leader who got
shot on a mission that i was in
uh he's in i think he's a preacher now i
want to say he's a preacher but uh we
keep in contact here and there on
on instagram and facebook and stuff like
that but
yeah i don't think that there's not one
guy or one sniper
that i don't have contact with
or at least you know six degrees of
separation somewhere on social media
you know i bet that makes sense because
i mean how many are there it's not like
it's a community of 300
or 600 000 small communities so and and
to do that you have to be part of a very
elite community
to decide to do that i mean it's not
easy i remember going out there even
just trying to shoot something that was
you know 200 meters away from you 100
meters away from 300 meters long
and then you're looking at numbers you
got to be how do you even do that to go
you know that far with some of the
things you know
you guys do so now let's let's go to the
other side is the mindset of would you
consider yourself a superstitious person
or no
superstitious i you know
yes would you say that's common amongst
your peers or no
i would i would say so i think that oh
yeah oh yeah
especially like on the last deployment
there's a big super
i was big into it everybody is that
you're gonna
die it's it's you're gonna get shot
you're gonna get wounded or you're gonna
die
it's gonna be a worse deployment and for
me it legitly
it legitimately was my worst scariest
deployment
and it i noticed that amongst everybody
who
i saw get out either they got shot and
it was just this thing that happened
and if things would not go right um
before a mission
or something was out of place or
something didn't happen as normal
oh yeah there's a big superstition
amongst that on friday the 13th or was
one for me
i didn't like doing things on holidays
um
you know what's kind of weird me out a
little bit doing missions on the holiday
i i can see that because you know there
is
there's so many attention like stuff
that has to do with details like look
everything's got to be good for me to
feel comfortable to make this so
what is that you know what so fast
forward to you
going on your tours and uh it's
33 confirmed in four months uh
what is the difference between your
first confirmed versus your 33rd come
from what was the difference between
nicholas on his first versus the 33rd
he my first one in my career ever i was
18.
i was a machine gunner with my first
ever and my first as a sniper
well i killed 33 as a sniper as a
machine gunner i legitimately have no
idea it was a few i would
maybe as much as uh a sniper maybe a
little bit less
but it was a it was a bit and the first
one
is a 18 year old kid i had a dream about
it
for many many years and as a sniper
it was a separation i think of how close
it was
like being able to see something and the
intent behind it
was more personal so i had the sniper
kills set
everything apart from any other kill and
every sniper kill that i had
was all weird not weird but
they all felt different yeah they all
felt different i never there was nothing
that feeling that some people say oh you
get used to it i never felt that
i never felt used to killing anything
i would have this weird set of emotions
that i would go through
and the motto for our sniper community
is uh without warning without remorse
without warning part nine times out of
ten is what happened but the remorse
part for me
personally was every single time i felt
some weird way about it
i'm not sure if it you know derives from
coming from a religious background
and you know growing up in church and
stuff like that but
i was it was weird it was a weird
experience for me to
after the fact really weird you're the
first person that i've heard say
the disposition that you have it's
typically the other way around which is
it's part of my job it's part of my duty
and i wanted to be and you know you know
you know
it's almost like a script that you hear
but you're you're saying yeah yeah
did you when you were active did you
have contact with your parents like did
you talk to your mom and dad could you
come in
so when the first time it happened as a
sniper did you call your mom and dad and
try to process it with them like here's
what i'm thinking how do i handle this
and what feedback is that i give you
my first kill ever i i remember going to
i was in iraq and i went to uh
across the street to this mwr place and
i forget what mwr stands for
um but it's the we had like computers
and stuff in there and
internet access um we could go in there
and
go online and make phone calls and i
called my dad my first kill ever
no i emailed him then called him and he
told me hey don't talk about that stuff
but i was like dad i killed somebody
and he's like hey don't talk about that
and you never talked about it after
any time after but it was my very first
kill ever
ever in combat it was like uh just eight
a little bit over 18
i was in to crit uh to crit
at that point yeah my first deployment
to iraq was the correct second one
was to mosel and third was the baghdad
so the crit was my first
kill ever mwr united states army
families
and moral welfare welfare and recreation
programs
there it is i knew that recreation was
in there yep that's what it was yeah
yeah so
and so so you call your dad and dad says
listen this is not something we talk
about so you're kind of like okay
i'm going to keep it to myself and you
go back at it and you're having 33
total and each one of them has a
different feeling and emotion for it
are you at a point right now where you
can live your normal life and it doesn't
haunt you anymore
i am now i would say i am now um
i think that maybe over time i don't
think it'd ever go away because it
happened
like there was a point in time where i
never wanted to forget any of this stuff
i thought it was it was just stuck and
i was fine with it it was who i it made
me who i was
at that moment but then it started to
like really affect my personal life and
family life and
that guy did not intermingle with this
world you know
too well so it took some time and it
honestly legitimately was the birth of
my son
uh four years ago four years ago was the
complete 100
turn around you know from being i had to
be it was just a weird weird thing i
from everything i've ever ever
experienced watching my son being born
in the room was like i don't know it was
out of body
experience maybe weird i've never felt
that before it's just really really
intense
really weird and and scary yeah
scary at the same time really scared
that was a different scared though but
it changed me in a good way
i just couldn't be i don't know it was
like
i didn't matter so much anymore it
wasn't being
like me you know what i mean i didn't
have to be me
it was like i have to be cool for this
guy
or different for this guy it was just a
weird
trend it was a weird thing you know
nicholas when's your birthday what
month's your birthday
november november 28th me and my son
share the same birthday
and weird weird weird thing happened
my son was born well he had this heart
condition
his uh heart would skip every once in a
while and
my sis my wife's sister just lost her
baby
12 hours 12 12 hours after she was born
she had a heart condition as well so i
was you know already worried about it
and the doctors were going to you know
induce labor
the i think it was december december 8th
is when they wanted to induce it
but when i first met my wife 13 years
ago
i told her i wanted to have a child no
later than 30
and on my birthday is when my son was
born i was like
so we share the same birthday now
november 28th
in november 20th 1990 is when i came to
america from
germany no november i mean i will never
forget november 28th oh you came to
you know what so did i i came to america
we moved from germany
in 1990 but yeah november 28th is uh
yeah my birthday in 1990s when we moved
to uh
florida in america from germany let me
tell you november 28 1990 is when i left
germany and i came to america
you're kidding no i was in germany i
came here
i was in germany by a military camp in
erlangen that had a refugee camp
and we went from there november 20 1990
i came to america
landed in new york ended up in glendale
california wow
so november 20th got a lot of meaning
for both of us it's your birthday
birthday you coming here and you know
for me it's me coming to the states
so you said something earlier you said
when i asked you i said tell me about
the first
versus the last number one number you
know 33 and you said you i had some
that wasn't even the confirmed snipers
it was you know different that i had to
the the
i think you said the uh uh what was the
weapon
gunner um the machine gun the machine
gun you said
well you said something about the last
one you said the last one was kind of
emotional
what do you mean by that you said
something about the last one
my very oh my very first one deployed
was the most emotional one i had the
most dreams about
it was when you said the first first
confirmed versus the last confirmed
you said the last confirmed had meaning
behind it you
it almost like the enemy was somebody
that took out a friend or something was
there was there a meaning behind the
last one
i would say we had more maybe along the
lines of the mission with uh where i
lost my friend benjamin cobb
if that's the one that were be not my
last
kill my last mission where it changed my
life
where i was never that was my
determining factor i was not gonna you
know re-enlist or anything my last
mission when
i almost lost my life my reconnaissance
team pinned down by an enemy sniper and
surrounded
and watching the guy come in to save our
life
and watching him die like five minutes
after that was when
you know i think was my determining
factor i don't think any kill actually
you know different from any other kill
they were all different
and all emotional i had remorse for all
of them i'm not going to say remorse i
felt sad though
it wasn't i did feel sad it was a
sadness but not like as sad as in
i wanted to cry necessarily maybe it
emptiness maybe like it didn't feel
good you know i don't i don't want to
say it felt great i didn't feel good
about it it was just
wow i don't know it was a weird weird
feeling yeah
interesting um uh uh uh so so your your
mk
11 rifle why the nickname you know you
put the nickname
modified version of the sr-25 sniper
rifle nicknamed
dirty diana why dirty diana michael
jackson
my first ever memory of michael jackson
was sitting on my mom's lap
watching him at a concert he was
performing
and he rips his shirt off on stage and
for some reason
all that the the fireworks and stuff
stuck with me
and michael jackson fan ever since
moonwalking at the age of you know five
or six
and i love i love michael jackson and
had michael jackson
on you know all my playlists but it
derives from this
operation we were doing in iraq and my
uh
this yeah we're riding around strikers
and in the striker
it's like a modified i want to say a
mini
if you think of a mini tank but with
wheels there's eight wheels on it
40 ton vehicle and i'm the driver
there's someone behind me who's like in
charge of looking out on top so i can
drive and
we call him the tc we get into a
firefight and this song
on his playlist the ipod ipad or ipod it
was at the time
we had plugged in into the internal
speakers and he had dirty diana
playing in on the internal speakers
during this firefight in iraq and
that was like my moment or i guess my
moment where i knew that
i don't know i was gonna name something
after it but at the time it wasn't a
sniper rifle it was just
i love michael jackson but when i got my
rifle in battalion i had to name it
dirty diana just out of
remembrance for you know michael jackson
i i don't know
i like the song i don't know i like
michael jackson i wasn't gonna name her
billy
billy jean would have been i don't know
dirty diana was it though
i like dirty diana i said that's a very
unique name to give you a rifle so
you know let's go to a different
direction with sniper so
did you did you study like where you
want to study who's the greatest sniper
of all time who are the top five who the
top ten you know
what do they do how many confirmed kills
what's the longest distance who is this
guy
were you somebody that got into it like
were you obsessed were you maniacal
about it
i was obsessed to the point my dad took
my books my library books away
oh what grade was i in i had to be
seventh or eighth grade at the time
i was getting in trouble in school from
i would go to the library
and either if i had a library card or
i would steal some books and check out a
few other ones but
all the military books that revolved
around sniping and all the vietnam
uh special operation guys like sog song
and
the old navy seals and i learned jesse
ventura was a navy seal from like one of
these books
and um one of my idols at the time was
carlos hathcock
a marine sniper and i had video uh vhs
tapes that i would come home after
school and watch and was consuming up
way too much of my time
uh interfering with school work and got
in trouble for it but
that was my idol and i think that to
this day that he is the best
hands down sniper of all time regardless
of numbers
but carlos has talked in my opinion is
the
top of the top when it comes to snipers
but tell me why because i know he had 93
confirmed in vietnam
i his ingenuity and the mission that
sets him apart from all
and i idolized him for it even on my
first uh reconnaissance mission was when
he went in to go take out the
uh vietcong commander he stalked in like
a thousand yards
on his stomach surrounded by himself it
was basically a suicide mission
and took out a commander a vietnamese
commander uh
then had to crawl back out while being
chased by a whole brigade or something
like that from
enemy troops uh getting bit by bugs and
putting grass and stuff through the back
of his uh the slits in the back of his
his uniform to essentially make a
ghillie suit
his ingenuity was i think would set him
apart for me
and uh his when he attached the united
scope to the
uh mahdi's 50 cal machine gun and sniped
someone off of a bike
uh one was like 1.2 miles away i think
and that was where we get the barrett
sniper rifle from to just stay the
semi-automatic
he was like the person who invented or
threw the theory out there to put a
scope on a 50-cal
rifle so i think that is why i put him
up there but that's what stood out
in his his persona about him he was just
a
white feather his persona and i don't
know he's a
sniper godlike figure to me yeah so i
looked up a few things to see kind of
what the numbers look like so craig
harrison british sniper killed the
taliban fighter
2475 meters away that's a mile and a
half in 2009 like
and then another canadian side couldn't
find out what the name was i kept
looking to see what's
they won't release his name yeah okay i
know about the first one
okay yeah the second one is 3540 meters
which is over two miles that's the world
record 39 football fields
and they're not disclosing the name for
whatever reason so
if you can kind of put us give us some
perspective what is 2475 meters or 3540
meters
my furthest shot is 2022 meters on a
steel target
that took the bullet a few seconds to
get there
let's say so 1.2 miles one well 2022
meters let's say is 1.1 1.2 miles
you're looking at flight time
five six seconds uh
five six seconds of flight time three
four five it depends on the round you're
using
um let's say 4 000 meters right uh
with the average sniper rifle 762
that would take the bullet 1.7 seconds
to get there so just under two seconds
for a thousand meters
so amplify that over time to let's say
you have to factor in the fact that the
bullet is slowing down now too so that
one point
two seconds or two seconds at a thousand
meters doubled
it's like four or five seconds three
thousand
two miles that is insane i would never
attempt the shot like that just because
what you're looking at in the scope
you would you that's phenomenal
like you're not really looking at
anything at that point imagine looking
at the crosshair and the scope
aiming at a crosshair that's what i
that's what that would look like it's to
get to that
that is a lot of that's confidence
confidence and time
confidence that's confidence you're
saying confidence why because is there a
little bit of assumption and luck behind
it
i would say a lot of luck but confidence
to even
attempt to take that shot i don't think
i would have i know
who i am i would have never even
attempted that how far away the guy's
two miles
negative why do you say never why do you
say never why do you say you would never
tempt that shot
i'm not i've never even done math out to
that point
i've never shot that far i
don't even i just wouldn't even do i'm
not comfortable i know for a fact
if i did hit i know it would be 100 luck
i didn't mean to hit the guy
i just put it out there i would pull the
trigger if i would take the shot but if
i hit him
pure luck i would never be able to do
that one more time
or ever again i don't know there's so
much stuff going on the spin of the
earth
2400 meters though i mean 2200 meters is
not like it's
i mean when i when i earlier said 100
200 300 meters i meant to say 120 to 300
yards because there's a big difference
between
but 2200 meters one mile is not that far
i would say
a mile shot maybe not the average per
well of course not but a mile
to a sniper is not that bad that's not
that far
on a human size target i take that back
is pretty hard that is actually hard
my further shot on a human target was
half mile but on
a steel target 2022 meters that is
pretty hard that took
two shots within three shots to get that
is actually tough but
two miles that is you're looking at a
crosshair through a crosshair or aiming
at a crosshair with a crosshair at that
point that's very very small
looking at a mile away at a human-sized
target is
i'm trying to make a comparison to what
that would be like looking at
it's something very if you stood across
your standard size room and maybe looked
at
the little hole inside of the
wall socket that's probably
from maybe 30 feet away that's what that
would look like
yeah or maybe the the head of a nail
yeah very very small i mean what your
your eyes
it is it then more on your vision
has it been more on how you set up your
is it then more on your you know
breathing what
what what is like you know bodybuilding
they say it's diet
then it's how you lift weights then it's
cardio say right
what's the top of the top of being a
sniper is it
what would you put at the top vision
wow i would say
the ability to calm no
the ability to understand nature if you
don't understand when
or you don't understand the humidity how
the temperature affects the bullet
if you don't have a co a a really really
good grasp on that
then you won't hit anything you won't
hit anything the wind could literally
you won't you could barely feel the wind
but at a mile you won't hit anything
not anything so you have to have a
really really really good grasp at the
top
math math and understanding nature once
you understand nature then that converts
to math
that math converts to the gun then that
goes to
the shooter after that then everything
after that you just pull the trigger
you just lay behind the gun a slab of
meat behind the gun is what we refer
refer to it as and then pull the trigger
wow
math is at the top oh yeah big time
big time a lot of calculus and a lot of
geometry a lot of geometry
were you good at both algebra what's
that
were you good at both geometry and
calculus
no i failed high school i graduated with
the 1.7
gpa i'm completely i'm terrible at math
but
it was not the type of math that i had
no real
uh i guess real intention to even it
didn't excite me
but after learning what you could do
with math applied to a bullet
like the pythagoras or the pythagoras
theorem are the
what's another equation simple equation
like a
was a squared plus b squared equals c
squared um
that equates a lot to like high angle
math um if i wanted to shoot off of a
rooftop
that's the exact or somewhat the exact
equation i would use for that
multiply by cosines and stuff but you
find out a lot about
how to hit a target by using math
everything inside the scope is all like
mill radian anyways
so um to find the distance to a target
you can use your scope reticle
and the little dots in there represent
measurements
units of measurement and that's how i
would figure out how far away a target
is by looking at
the size of a target with these little
dots in there multiplied by
a number a constant number depending on
the size of the target
divided by how many dots i see in my
scope and
that's how all that math comes out to be
unbelievable to be thinking about how
math maybe that's another commonality
amongst the guys is that
you have to be somewhat good at numbers
to be able to do what you guys do
absolutely and i found they're good at
working stuff out in their head a lot
that's
uh there we go there we go maybe that's
why i think the guys are quiet the way
they are a lot of stuff happens up here
there's a lot of talkative stuff but
everything happens up here so
that's what it is that's what it is
thinkers yeah
there it is yeah interesting so uh do
you still uh do you still uh uh
carry you know do you still uh have guns
and you go shooting still is it still
part of your life
literally an hour and a half before i
started this
interview i was at the range
oh yeah what do you do full time now
what's your full-time gift today
write books write books i write other
people's books and
i just now have enough time to where i
can work on uh the stuff that i want to
work on not so much like military but
you know the things that used to excite
me as a kid you know like fiction or
you know uh science fiction and stuff
like that and
uh history and you know books that may
not pertain so much towards
combat you know but things that
intrigued me
i tell you you got an impressive resume
for a guy that had a 1.7 gpa becomes a
sniper who needs to be getting map
and then after leaving the army becomes
an author that needs to write so so
whatever that one pointed out
was maybe not a lot of accuracy behind
it uh
uh final question here about
uh uh your four-year-old son one day
comes up to you he's
18 he says dad i want to be a sniper
what do you tell him do you encourage
him or discourage him or let him do
whatever he wants to do
i would tell him yes only under one
condition it's for the olympics
you can be the precision shooters and
the olympics those the the ones that
that ski
are they cross country ski yeah then
they shoot yeah he could do that
i would train him uh invest all the time
i ever needed
if he only did that but to take another
life
absolutely absolutely not absolutely not
so you would 100
discourage him 100 100 i've changed
i'm telling you i've changed my views on
a lot
like there was a point in my life where
i lost spirituality you know i
questioned a lot
a lot and been having the birth of him
and
getting seeing things differently and
understanding things differently getting
back into
spirituality and the understanding of
how things work and how much
you need different things in life i just
don't
i don't see the need to want to put that
if he were to take another life and how
it would affect him potentially after
the fact you know i was able to i feel
that i'm able to
or was able to recoup or recover from
the
the mental aspect from it and move on
but
for some people it's not that easy and i
just wouldn't want that burden
to be on anybody you know let alone my
son
so i've changed my view on that i think
that there's a time like
for for sport i think it's great
no issue with it and if it was a last
resort defending my family but to
to take life i it's it's weird it's a
weird experience to live through i just
don't think it's right
i think we should step away from killing
for a little bit and
love love everybody for you know give
that a try for a second
i i i think america definitely needs to
work on that a little bit the next few
years
oh yeah see how that helps us out we
need to maybe listen to a little bit
more bob marley
and a little bit here we go easy or
maybe get off a little bit of tupac for
a couple years i don't know we can we
can hang out we can hang out come to
texas
well i gotta well i i know you're a big
fan of san antonio it sounds like you're
a die-hard senator
lee and charles barkley
oh my gosh but anyways man i really
enjoyed talking to you seriously i
really enjoyed talking to you
uh thank you for your service thank you
for just being you and transparent what
an incredible story for people that are
watching this i know you got another
uh real cool uh skit that you did with
inside insider where you're talking
about 11 sniper movies are they real are
they not real
and that's kind of how we found you you
know that popped up i'm like what a
great story you know let's get them on
and
kai recommended you and i'm so glad we
had you on brother thank you so much
thank you thank you much appreciate it
take care buddy you too 33 confirmed
kills
wouldn't recommend his four-year-old son
to be a sniper if you wanted to be one
every single
one of the confirmed mess with his head
a little bit up until the kid was born
son was born four years ago
just a very genuine guy that you could
tell he was thinking about
the right answer the most accurate
answer to give during the interview i
enjoyed it a lot
here's to know what you took away from
it comment below and if you enjoyed this
interview i think you will also enjoy
the interview with taya kyle
who was the wife of chris kyle the
american sniper played by bradley cooper
if you've never watched that one
it's a very very different angle click
over here
to watch that interview take care
everybody bye-bye